Hi, I'm Lilli Thompson and I'm a Game Developer
Advocate with the Google Chrome team.
Today, I'd like to talk to you about creating
cross platform games with PlayN.
It's an exciting time to be a game developer.
We have more opportunities to reach fans than
ever before: through smart phones, smart TVs,
social networks, HTML5, and other awesome
new technology.
But here's the challenge: as developers, we
see this opportunity and want to connect with
all those players, but reaching them is a
huge amount of work.
In order to really get your game out there,
you have to create many different versions.
One build for Android, another for iOS, another
for HTML5, still another for Flash users,
and so on for whatever platforms you want
to target.
And that costs a huge amount of development
time, it's hard to maintain, and bottom line:
it's just no fun.
That's where PlayN comes in.
PlayN is a Google open source project that
allows you take a single body of source code
and compile it into versions that run natively
as HTML5, Android, Java, or Flash.
How does that work?
You get the PlayN source code and write your
game using a core set of APIs that abstract
out platform-specific functionality.
Then you take that platform-agnostic source
code, and with the press of a button, PlayN
can generate native versions for every platform
it supports.
And that's really what PlayN is all about:
one game, one code base, many platforms.
Get your game into the hands of users as efficiently
as possible, and have fun while you're doing
it.
Download PlayN now and try it for yourself!